bare hands heading into the after a
heated conversation with the official
gotta get your emotions out somehow he
coached up these guys pretty tough he
was hard on them coach I need to talk to
you about what you've been doing in the
weight room because um you had a
performance here in the timeout huddle
when this thing you you snapped this
like these are harder to break than
those old cardboard ones that lapis had
that's what he said he wouldn't have
been strong enough to break this so
um is that a gift for lap yeah keep it
at the lap all right it's just part of
the fun I'm glad you're making fun of me
but I love it man it was uh you know
what
we're gonna coach guys we're gonna do
what we do instead of you know not
letting them get away with this and that
we're gonna be hard on him because
defense wins games especially in the
NCAA tournament we appreciate you coach
thank you